اعرب الامين العام للامم المتحده عن قلقه
من تداعيات الاوضاع في السودان على
المنطقه لاسيما دول الجوار بسبب ما قال
انها الطبيعه الهشه التي تعانيها تلك
الدول وكان مسؤولون اقليميون ودوليون قد
حذروا من احتمال تمدد الصراع السوداني الى
الدول المجاوره بجانب تاثيرات الانسانيه
والاقتصاديه للمواجهات في السودان على
الدول المجاوره له
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى جديه التحذيرات
من تداعيات تدهور الاوضاع الامنيه في
السودان على دول الجوار وما ابرز
التهديدات التي تواجه هادئه او تواجهها
هذه الدول في حال استمرار هذه الحرب وما
هي خيارات دول الجوار للتعامل مع
التداعيات المختلفه للمواجهات المسلحه فيه
وما الادوات التي تملكها لتخفيف وطاه
نتائج هذه المواجهات والى اي مدى يمكن ان
تؤثر الاتهامات التي طالت بعض جيران
السودان بالتدخل في صراعه المسلح على
ادوارهم المنتظره في احتواء هذا الصراع
[موسيقى]
في سياق قلق اقليميا ودوليا من احتمال
امتداد تاثيرات المواجهات المسلحه في
السودان بين الجيش والدعم السريع والتي
تجاوزت ثلاثه اسابيع جاءت تحضيرات الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش من
اثيوبيا المجاوره مما سماه تداعيات
الاوضاع في السودان على المنطقه سيما دول
الجوار التي قال ان طبيعتها الهشه تجعلها
اكثر عرضه لهذه التداعيات التي يخشى من ان
تمتد لاكثر من عشرين دوله في المنطقه
يقطنها نحو نصف مليار نسمه
[موسيقى]
جزيلا طبعا السودان جغرافيا يقع في منطقه
فيها كثير من بؤل التوتر يعني كلنا بنعرف
الازمه المتطاوله وعدم الاستقرار في
الصومال امتد لعقود وايضا الازمه التي
حدثت في اقليم التقراي قبل نحو سنتين
اثيوبيا ما تزال يعني تستعيد عافيتها
تدريجيا من ذلك الصراع فوقوع الازمه في
السودان اكيد يعني بحكم الترابط الجغرافي
يثير القلق لكن ايضا هنالك جوانب لابد من
الاشاره اليها بين السودان واثيوبيا بنعرف
ان هنالك مشاكل حول اقليم الفشله وان
الجيش السوداني فرض سيطرته عليه من طرف
المجموعات المسلحه الاثيوبيه خلال حرب
التقراي فهنالك الازمات المكتومه التي
يمكن ان تثير القلق طبعا من الناحيه الغرب
ايضا بحكم التداخل الجغرافي بين السودان
وتشاد
وبعض المجموعات التي
بدات تتحرك نحو تشاد طبعا في بدايه الازمه
كان هنالك التقارير تحدثت عن مئات من
القوات الذين دخلوا تشاد واضطرت السلطات
الشياطين ان تنزع منهم اسلحتهم يبدو انها
تتبع لقوات الدعم السريع
اضافه لما ورد على لسان القوات المسلحه
السوداني ان دولتين في الاقليم لهما صله
بالتمرد الذي حدث من قوات الدعم السريع
تحدثوا عن في اشاره واضحه الى افريقيا
الوسطى والى ليبيا هذه المؤشرات طبعا بكل
تاكيد تظهر
الترابط في عالم اليوم والسودان ليست حاله
حاله الحرب في السودان او النزاع في
السودان ليست الحاله الوحيده احنا شاهدنا
كثير من اقاليم العالم الاحداث قد تندلع
في دوله واحده ولكن الترابط في عالم اليوم
يجعل لهذه الازمات تداعياتها تبدا
بالانسانيه والاقتصاديه وتمتد الى حتى
اثاره النزاعات في المجاوره من هذا
المنطلق اعتقد جاء قلق الامين العام لكن
في تقدير ملاحظه ايضا انه على الامين
العام ايضا ان يقلق من اداء بعثه الامم
المتحده الدائم الموجوده في السودان لانها
كانت موجوده وتراقب الوضع وكانت تشرف على
العمليه السياسيه التي خلقت حاله من
التوتر وادى الانفجار الاوضاع بهذه
الطريقه طيب يعني اشرت الى اكثر من نقطه
سناتي على تفصيلها خلال هذه الحلقه من ما
وراء الخبر ولكن دعني اسمع من السيده
مستوى شيخو سيد موسى عفوا سيد موسى يعني
هل تتفق دول الجوار مع تقييم غوتيريش هل
تخشى من تمدد هذا الصراع وتاثيراته على
دولها
نعم مرحبا بكم بالساده المشاهدين وبضيفك
الكريم نعم لا شك في ذلك المخاوف من
الازمه في السودان
وانعكاساتها على الدول المجاوره امر ليس
بجديد
فتسارعت كثير من دول الجوار الى هذه الى
تاكيد هذه التصريحات
التاثير قد لا يقتصر ايضا على الدول
المجاوره فقط وانما قد يتمدد الى الدول
جوار الجوار يعني سبع دول الان مجاوره
للسودان
وهناك الدول المجاوره ايضا لهذه الدول نحن
نتحدث عن حوالي 20 او 22 دوله
ربما تتاثر بهذه
الاشتباكات او الحرب التي تجري في السودان
وايضا هناك السودان ليس مجاور
للدول الافريقيه فقط هناك السودان مصدر
غذاء
يعني سله غذاء العالم العربي كثير من
الصادرات تذهب للدول العربيه اذا هذه
المخاوف لا تقتصر فقط على دول الجوار
السوداني وانما تمتد الى دول العالم
العربي مصر من هناك في الشمال وليبيا
وهناك ايضا
تنبع هذه المخاوف خاصه ان ثلاثه اسابيع
مرت على المواجهات ولا تزال اثار هذه
المواجهات على دول الجوار
محدوده او على الاقل لم تخرج من تحت
السيطره بالتالي من اين تاتي هذه المخاوف
لم تخرج من السيطره ولكنها اكيد انها تخرج
عن السيطره
الزميل الضيف تحدث عن انعكاسات
الحرب في السودان على اثيوبيا لان اثيوبيا
كانت منذ عامين يعني كانت في اشتباكات
مماثله هناك حوالي يعني مليونين اثيوبي من
النازحين ومن غير النازحين يعيشون في
السودان هذه الجموع الغفيره اذا اتجهت الى
اثيوبيا وهناك ايضا من يعني نفس الوضع في
اريتريا ونفس الوضع في تشاد الحديث الان
يعني عن حوالي 100 الف
نجحوا الى
تشاد تقريبا وكذلك في المعابر السودانيه
المصريه معبر اركن بالتحديد الحديث عن
حوالي 30 الف
فجنوب السودان ايضا هذه الدول
اغلب هذه الدول يعني الوضع فيها هش كما
اشار فيه اليها الامين العام للامم
المتحده هذه الهشاشيه تاتي هشاشيه امنيه
وانسانيه ويعني
فضروري توفير الدعم اللازم لهؤلاء
لهذه الموجات البشريه التي تنطلق الى هذه
الدول وايضا
هناك اشاره الى
الجماعات المسلحه السودان
يعاني من فسائل المصلحه كانت قد وقعت
اتفاقا مع الحكومه وهذه الفصائل وقعت
الاتفاق على نزع السلاح ولم تنزع السلاح
ايضا فهذه الفصائل
هناك تصريح لحاكم اقليم
الى حد الامن الى حد الان لم تتدخل لكن
اطاله امد الصراع يعني امتداد هذه
الاشتباكات مثلا الى خارج الخرطوم
وطول الوقت قد يفجر الازمه هذه الازمه لن
تقتصر على السودان هذه الفصائل المسلحه
ايضا قد يعني تحتاج الى ان تحمي نفسها
فانعكاسات وارتدادات هذه
الامور يمتد الى الدول الجوار وهذا ما
اشار اليه الامين العام للامم المتحده سيد
صلاح الدين الزين السيد موسى اشار الى
تاثيرات الاقتصاديه الانسانيه ناشئه عن
اللجوء وايضا الى تاثيرات امنيه هل هذه هي
فقط التاثيرات المتوقعه او المحتمله على
دول الجوار ام ترى بان التاثيرات ممكن ان
تذهب ابعد من ذلك
هو طبعا هنالك يعني قضايا اكبر يعني مثلا
بالنسبه
الاوضاع في السودان بنعرف انه منذ التغيير
الذي حدث في 2019 دول الاقليم لها مصالح
لها متقاطعه
لان كل واحد يساهم في ترتيب الاوضاع في
السودان طبعا مع مراعاه مصالحه يعني مثلا
اثيوبيا ساعه للعب دور كبير في فتره 2019
2020 الذي ادى لتشكي تشكيل قدر من التوافق
ما بين العسكريين والمدني في ذلك الوقت
وهذه المساله طبعا في اطار التنافس بينها
وبين مصر حول موضوع سد النهضه وخلق
الانزعاجا داخل الحكومه المصريه من هذا من
هذه الناحيه نقطه اخرى انا فقط اريد ان
اوضح انه القضيه فيها جوانب واضحه جدا
يعني مثلا موضوع الفشقه في الشرق السودان
كانت هنالك جماعات هي ليست الحكومه
الاثيوبيه بشكلها الرسمي ولكن جماعات
مسلحه تضع يدها على هذه المنطقه
عليها الجيش السوداني تحرك واستعاد
السيطره السودانيه على منطقه الفشقه الان
بسبب النزاع الموجود في الخرطوم وتحرك
القوات السودانيه بسبب هذا الصراع اذا لا
سمح الله اعاده هذه المجموعات مره اخرى
فقد يخلق توترا في هذه المنطقه مجددا طبعا
لا يوجد مؤشر حقيقي انه سيحدث ذلك لكن ليس
مستبعدا تماما قد يقع ذلك وبالتالي ممكن
يخلق حاله من التوتر واذا حدث ذلك ربما
ايضا
حركه قوات الدعم السريعه التي تقع تحت
الضغط من قبل قوات المسلحه الان ربما ترحب
بذلك باعتبار انه اذا حصل توتر في الحدود
فيقلل الضغط العسكري الذي تواجهه الان
فهنالك قضايا حقيقيه يمكن
اثيوبيا والسودان سيد صلاح الدين الزين
يعني اشرت الى هذه الاثار التي تحدثت عنها
وتحدثت عن دول تدعم قوات الدعم السريع
حسبما ذكرت ولكن هل هي فقط هذه الدول ام
ان هنالك دول اخرى تدعم الجهات الاخرى في
السودان تتدخل لدعمه نعم هو دعنا ننظر
للموضوع في اطار الاوسع
الدول الجوار ككل في تقديري انها لا تريد
ولا ترغب ان ترى
وجود جيشين في السودان ولا تريد ولا ان
ترى سيطره ماليشيا او قوه خارجه عن سيطره
الدوله على الاوضاع في السودان بمعنى اخر
ان هنالك توجه عام وسمعنا التصريحات التي
صدر سواء كان من جمهوريه مصر من اريتريا
البيان الجامعه العربيه اليوم الذي صدر
طبعا فيها مجموعه من الدول العربيه
المجاوره السودان كلها تؤكد على اهميه
الشرعيه المؤسسات الرسميه في السودان وهذا
يعني القوات المسلحه بحكم الامر الواقع هي
الان تحكم الاوضاع في السودان نعم لكي لا
نبتعد كثيرا عن الموضوع ولكن قوات الدعم
خطر على دول الجوار ايضا
نعم لا شك في ذلك صحيح ان السودان يقدر
على حل مشاكله بنفسه ولدى السودان من
المخزون يعني ومن الثقافات ايضا ما يمكنه
من ذلك لكن
اندلاع هذه الاشتباكات فوجئت
وكان السودانيون يعولون على ان يحسم الجيش
السوداني هذه الاشتباكات خلال ايام ومع
طول امد الحرب
بدا الناس يعني بدات هذه المخاوف تتخطى
السودانيين لتصل الى دول الجوار فالتداخل
القبلي يعني
القوات الدعم السريع خلفياتها من
الدارفورد وامتدادها الى التشاد
وتحالفاتها مع الدول
الاقليميه والحديث مع اندلاع الاشتباكات
الحديث عن تحالفات اوسع دوليه
نسجتها قوات الدعم السريع ارعب دول الجوار
لا بد ان
الرجوع الى الجيش الوطني الواحد هو ما
تتمناه كل الدول الجوار رغم ان الدعم
السريع جزء من الجيش السوداني لكنه تمرد
لكن كل الناس يتمنى ان
تكون الامور تحت مظله الجيش السوداني لكن
الذي نراه الان ان
تحركات قوات الدعم السريع وتحالفاتها
اثارها تمتد الى دول الجوار واظن
انعكاسات الدوله الاولى المتدرجه يبدا من
تشاد ثم
اثيوبيا ثم مصر فطول امد الحرب ايضا قد
مساله اخرى مساله الارهاب الدولي في مصر
كانت تعاني منذ سنوات يعني من الارهاب
فيعني الجو المفتوح الان من دون ان يسيطر
احد الفريقين على الوضع في السودان قد
يفتح ايضا امام الجماعات الارهابيه
المسلحه وهناك ايضا مخاوف من الهجره الغير
الشرعيه العصابات كل هذه الامور
فموقع السودان
الجيوسياسي
والاستراتيجي قد يفتح الباب امام مشاكل لا
تعد ولا تحصى فهذه هي مخاوف دول الجوار
بينما هي الامتداد القبلي هو المخاوف
الابرز الان لكن
المخاوف الامنيه والعسكريه والسياسيه
والاقتصاديه هي قائمه يعني اشرتم الى
مخاوف على مستويات مختلفه وهنا اعود الى
السيد صلاح الدين الزين يعني مخاوف امنيه
مخاوف عسكريه مخاوف
اقتصاديه انسانيه بالتالي سيد صلاح ما
الذي تمتلكه هذه الدول من ادوات وما الذي
تقوم به من اجل تخفيف من وطاه هذه
المواجهات واثارها على دولها
اولا طبعا قبل وقوع هذه الاشتباكات يعني
السودان كانت لديه اتفاقات منذ عهد النظام
السابق مع العديد من دول الجوار لتامين
الحدود ما بين هذه الدول من ذلك قوات
مشتركه بين السودان وتشاد قوات مشتركه بين
السودان وافريقيا الوسطى وايضا طبعا في
اتفاقات وترتيبات مع دوله جنوب السودان
وقطعا فيما يتعلق بشقه الشرقي مع اثيوبيا
هناك ايضا تفاهمات التي تحتاج هذه الدول
هو تامين الحدود وان لا تصبح الحدود بين
السودان وهذه الدول مسرحا للتحرك العصابات
والجماعات لانه في اطار الصراع الدائره
حاليا في الخرطوم الواضح جدا انه القوات
الدعم السريع تحت اصرار قيادتها في مواجهه
القوات المسلحه لم تعد بنفس قوه التي بدات
قبل ثلاثه اسابيع وقد تتحول الى مجموعات
تتحرك فاذا تحركت عبر الحدود بالذات
بالاتجاه الغربي نعم سؤالي كان عن الدول
المجاوره للسودان وما التي تمتلكه من
ادوات
لتخفيف من وطئه هذه المواجهات القضيه
الاولى قضيه الاولى هي قضيه امنيه بالدرجه
الاولى هي تامين الحدود لان الان كثير من
التقارير تتحدث ان هنالك ارتال من القوات
تاتي من الناحيه الغربيه في محاوله للحاق
بالاشتباكات في الخرطوم ومن ناحيه الغربيه
ليست كلها فقط من دارفور هنالك تقارير
عديده تشير الى مجموعه حتى من خارج الحدود
تحاول ان تاتي فهذه نقطه تحتاج الى تامين
الحدود طبعا الجانب الاخر هو جانب السياسي
دبلوماسي من خلال الاصرار على معالجه هذه
المشكله وقف الاقتتال ووضع حد لهذا الصراع
بما يضمن استقرار السودان نظرا لان عدم
استقرار السودان لا سمح الله ليس فقط
سيؤثر على حدود السودان ولكن كما راينا
المؤشرات يمكن ان تمتد اثاره الى دول
الجوار وبالتالي على هذه الدول ان تتحرك
باتجاه ايجاد حل جذري لهذا الصراع وليس
فقط
البحث عن فقط مجرد تهدئه او هدنه اليوم او
غدا او ما الى ذلك النقطه الاخيره هي قضيه
في الشقه الانساني طبعا كثير من الناس
الذين
نزحوا الى بعض الدول مثلا دوله جنوب
السودان في نازحين من جنوب السودان او
اللاجئين موجودين في السودان الجزء كبير
منهم الان بدا العوده الى جنوب السودان
مثلما ايضا يحدث في الشقه الشرقي وبالتالي
هذا تفرض عليهم اعباء انسانيه كبيره لابد
من ان تصدوا لها بمعاونه الوكالات الامميه
التي
سيد موسى يعني ما قدره دول الجوار على
ايجاد فعلا مبادره ممكن ان ترضي الطرفين
من اجل الجلوس على طاوله الحوار
انا اعتقد ان الدول الدول الجوار خاصه مصر
واثيوبيا
وايضا دول اخرى الا تتنافسا في في السودان
وان يعمل بدفع الطرفين لايقاف الحرب لدى
مصر من الادوات ما يجعلها
تؤثر في مجريات الامور في السودان ولد
اثيوبيا ايضا ادوات اثيوبيا كانت لعبه
دورا كبيرا في الوصول الى اتفاقيه
الفرقاء في السودان قبل سنتين تقريبا
وايضا تحركت منذ بدايه الاشتباكات يعني
شكلت لجنه لضبط الحدود وتسهيل عبور
السودانيين وغير السودانيين وكذلك دعت
الاطراف يعني اتصلت بكل من حميده وكذلك
البرهان لايقاف الحرب اذن يعني لابد من
الدول الجوار ان يدفع الطرفان ايقاف الحرب
فهذه الحاجه الملحه ثم التركيز على
وضع الانساني
الحاجات الملاحكه كثيره منها الوضع
الانساني شكرا لك سيد موسى الشيخ الباحثه
في الشؤون الافريقيه كنت معنا من اديس
ابابا وشكر موصول لسيد صلاح الدين زين
الخبير في الشان السوداني من الدوحه
لهنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]